[Music]
I don't want to, I don't want to
die, I don't want to die.
Why, why are you doing this?
[Music] You
seem young,
or rather,
young.
This is a dream. What's happening now is real. It's a
memory of the guillotine. It's
not a dream.  I am the
empire's only deduction,
Neadunatiam.
I should have been executed, but for some reason I have returned to my 12-year-old self.
But everything is written in this diary. I
will try again. For the future of the country, for the
sake of the people.
In order for me to avoid the guillotine,
Pia
Moon Empire Story: A
reversal story of a princess's reincarnation that begins with the guillotine
[Music] It
will be made into a TV anime in 2023
[Music]